gros mersch pour le groupe l'est
républicain merci monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur j'ai associé
guillaume larrivé eric ciotti jean
frédéric poisson
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur la
police technique et scientifique est au
coeur de l'action policière
un maillon incontournable tant pour
incriminer que pour innocenter ceux qui
sont plus communément et appelé les
experts subissent des contraintes
similaire à celle des policiers actifs
alors qu'ils n'ont pas le statut des
policiers puisqu'ils sont des agents
administratifs
à ce titre ils sont exposés à des
contraintes comme l'obligation d'être
accompagné d'anne officier de police
judiciaire sur le terrain les primes qui
constituent un tiers de leur salaire ne
sont pas intégrées dans le calcul de
leur retraite contrairement aux
policiers hier dans toute la france
les agents de la police scientifique se
sont mobilisés pour exprimer leur
profond de colère devant l'absence de
respect manifesté à leur égard lors de
la campagne présidentielle de 2012
françois hollande leur avait promis et
écrit un statut d'actif
trois ans plus tard rien n'a changé au
contraire vous ne cessez de revenir sur
cette promesse
le retour sur la parole donnée le non
respect des engagements sont devenus une
marque de fabrique de ce gouvernement
depuis plus d'un an
les syndicats de la police scientifique
réunis en intersyndicale négocier avec
vous aujourd'hui ces négociations sont
suspendues sans explication ils ne
demandent pas d'effectifs
supplémentaires il ne ment pas
d'augmentation de salaires seulement de
la reconnaissance et l'intégration de
leurs primes dans le calcul de leur
retraite
alors monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur a les loups allez vous
continuer à traiter ces fonctionnaires
de la police scientifique comme des
fonctionnaires de seconde zone ou allez
vous considérez les considérer comme
partie intégrante des forces de sécurité
que comptez vous faire pour répondre
enfin aux attentes légitimes de cette
police scientifique je vous remercie
merci madame la députée la parole est à
monsieur bernard cazeneuve ville à
l'intérieur
madame
la députée il y a deux parties dans
votre question une partie qui correspond
à des informations justes et une partie
qui correspond à des informations
erronées je souhaite donc par conséquent
pouvoir vous apporter toutes les
informations utiles ce qui est juste
c'est l'importance du travail que vous
avez souligné à juste titre dans votre
question que fait la police scientifique
et technique est pas une police
entièrement à part quelques police à
part entière qui doit être reconnu en
raison des missions très importantes
qu'elle accomplit dans le domaine de l'e
l'élucidation des actes de délinquance
dans le domaine du démantèlement des
filières du crime organisé dans le
domaine de la lutte antiterroriste et
nous avons vu au cours des derniers mois
sur un certain nombre de théâtre très
important le travail significatif est
par la police scientifique et technique
donc ce que vous dites est juste de ce
point de vue là et ça correspond à la
préoccupation du gouvernement ce qui
n'est pas juste en revanche c'est que
les négociations seraient rompues et que
le gouvernement ne voudrait rien faire
et je voudrais vous apportez tout
élément de nature à vous rassurer sur ce
point d'abord les négociations elles
sont continues le président de la
république a reçu les organisations de
la police scientifique et technique il
ya de cela dix jours et leur a donné
toutes garanties quant à la volonté qui
est la nôtre de prendre en compte ce que
sont les demandes qu'ils expriment
deuxièmement mon cabinet est en relation
constante avec la police scientifique et
technique et nous avons fait une
proposition très concrète à la police
scientifique et technique qui consiste à
offrir un dispositif indemnitaire qui
permettra aux agents de la police
scientifique et technique d'avoir une
prime annuelle supplémentaire compris
entre 1700 et 2000 euros
ce n'est quand même pas rien et
d'intégrer cette prime dans le calcul de
la retraite et les organisations
syndicales de la police scientifique et
technique doivent communiquer à mon
cabinet d'ici à la fin de la semaine de
nouvelles propositions de manière à ce
que la discussion se poursuive
je crois donc qu'il faut sur ces sujets
là toujours essayer d'apporter des
éléments d'informations exactes
est ce que je viens de vous donner
correspond très exactement ce que nous
faisons
la parole est à monsieur michel